we're going to start with this excerpt
from chapter 7 of a hunter-gatherer's
guide to 21st century uh chapter being
sex and gender i'm going to read a what
is it you actually chose this section
this week so we actually read the audio
we recorded the audiobook this week both
of us are going to be
doing that when that comes out september
14th um
so i already read this aloud once this
week
but this is the section you chose from
the sex and gender chapter called
division of labor
already in the chapter we've walked
through sort of all of the
all of the basic biology and
evolutionary biology of what sex is what
sexual reproduction is why there's two
you know why we don't change sex all of
that
division of labor
in many modern households women clean
the floors and men take out the trash
in some households those roles might be
switched and it might be true that both
members of a pair bond spend equal time
doing domestic work but it's fairly rare
for both partners to do every domestic
task in equal measure
this is division of labor
from many angles the division of labor
makes sense it has even been argued that
division of labor by the sexes is what
made us human
even if we don't accept that conclusion
we can agree that it's efficient and
generally a good use of everyone's time
saving time by dividing up the work
leaves more time for things we might
want to do more of like play or sex
the division of labor can and has
created rigid roles however many of
which are outdated in the 21st century
it is useful to understand some of where
those roles came from in order to
determine which ones are unlikely to
change and which ones might
from the earliest inequalities in
investment in gametes females and males
have engaged each other and the world
differently
among hunter-gatherers men have been far
more likely to be hunters of large game
women more likely to be gatherers of
plant foods and smaller animals
hunter-gatherer women likely spent most
of their adult pre-menopausal lives
pregnant or breastfeeding infants and
toddlers
when breast milk is all or most of a
child's diet the mother is effectively
on birth control as she experiences
physiologically induced amenorrhea
she cannot get pregnant when
breastfeeding at frequent intervals this
keeps birth intervals relatively long
and the birth rate fairly low
jump forward to the human transformation
of landscapes with agriculture and
gender roles become even more
constrained being tied to a particular
piece of land we were now more sedentary
and had ample grain stores with which to
supplement our and our children's diets
at any time
agriculturalist women thus experienced a
decrease in the birth interval babies
came at a faster rate and so the birth
rate climbed
this increase in fertility tied women to
hearth and home and we saw a concomitant
decrease
i think it's kind of competent
i think so too yeah we saw a concomitant
decrease in women's roles in economic
religious and other culturally important
realms
men and women exhibit so many
differences it would be impossible to
catalog them all here before we mention
just a few more another reminder about
populations is an order when we say that
men are taller than women the words on
average are implied
pointing to the existence of your friend
rhonda who really is quite tall does not
negate the statistical truth that on
average men are still taller than women
some of the average differences between
the sexes include that men have more
investigative interests while women have
more artistic and social interests
men are also on average more interested
in math science and engineering
on tests girls score higher in literacy
while boys score higher in math
and although average intelligence is the
same between boys and girls the
variability in intelligence is not there
are more boy geniuses and more boy
complete dullards than there are girls
in either category
one interesting piece of neuroscience
reveals that across several domains
including both emotional memory and
spatial ability women are better at
details men are better at gist
this finding manifests for instance in
the average man's superior ability to
remember a route and the average woman's
superior ability to remember the
location of the keys the cup of coffee
the document in need of being signed
the differences between the sexes are
found in babies and across cultures too
so this is not some weird weird
phenomenon
given a choice neonate girls spend more
time looking at faces while neonice boys
spend more time looking at things
and across cultures work is gendered
early
in an analysis of 185 cultures in every
culture studied some tasks are always
gendered in the same direction iron
smelting the hunting of large marine
mammals metal working all of these are
done by men only in those cultures that
do these things at all
more interesting is the tasks that are
highly gendered across cultures but for
which some cultures curtail female
involvement while other cultures curtail
male involvement these include weaving
the preparation of skins and the
gathering of fuel among others
this suggests that there is a value in
the division of labor even when neither
sex is inherently better at the task
consider also the pueblo people who have
long been understood to be master
ceramicists
it has been it had been assumed given
contemporary patterns that pottery
making was exclusively the domain of
women
in chaco canyon however in the four
corners area of the american southwest a
different story is emerging
when chaco canyon was a rapidly growing
religious and political center 1000
years ago the population was expanding
and with it the demand for pottery
more and more vessels were needed to
carry and store grain and water so
gender norms loosened and men began
doing this otherwise highly gendered
work
what might we learn from these truths we
can learn that gender roles can be
reupped for modernity some men will
prefer hearth and home to a grueling
career that is facilitated by having a
spouse taking care of the domestic
duties and some women will prefer the
latter
but many men and women we argue will
prefer
excuse me
but many men and women we argue will
prefer to be restricted to neither
domain
without being slaughtered into
preconceived roles many people of both
sexes will prefer a partner who is their
equal without being identical
we can learn from a more nuanced
understanding of gendered work the
traditionalist appeals to women not
working outside of the home or to men
being dominant in economic and business
matters are aggressive without any
nugget of necessity or truth
historically women and men have had
division of labor both in family units
and in societies but other than those
tasks mandated by anatomy and physiology
gestation lactation there is little in
the modern world that some women might
not choose to do
similarly men are ever more welcome in
traditionally female fields such as
nursing and teaching although we
shouldn't expect parity there either
different preferences lead to different
choices pretending that we are identical
rather than ensuring that we are equal
under the law
is a fool's game
and one more so we we have a corrective
lens section at the end of every chapter
and uh the final one for this chapter
is
recognize that our differences
contribute to our collective strength
if we more highly value the work that
women are more likely to be drawn to eg
teaching social work nursing perhaps we
could stop demanding equal
representation of men and women in
fields that women are simply not as
likely to be interested in
recognizing that we are on average
different is the critical first step to
building a society in which all
opportunities are truly open to everyone
equal opportunity is an honorable goal
in step with reality whereas aiming for
equal outcome in which every occupation
from daycare workers to garbage
collectors has equal representation
between the sexes will disappoint
everyone involved
yeah i i always wonder if uh those who
apply these very um naive equalizing
kinds of
uh remedy proposals if they have
contemplated what it would be like to
live in the world that they are
imagining yeah i mean and this came up
in the in that event that uh that i did
years ago now with james damore in the
wake of the google memo
um this this was very much in this and
that had peter pagosian and helen plecos
as well and you introduced us um back
before we lived in portland but it was
an event here at portland state
university um
exactly exactly this came up right like
we also don't hear the cry from the the
gender activists
for there to be equity
in the sexes among garbage collectors
right there's plenty of dangerous or
banal or dirty work that men are far
more likely to do
and no that doesn't pay particularly
well and we're not hearing that we need
equity there um what we're hearing about
is in those fields and i actually in
that event i pushed back against james
james damore a little bit
um because
it is true that
um
the work that uh men are more likely on
average to be interested in doing does
pay better and this does have to do with
historical record of sexism like and we
have inherited that and this is you know
in this way unlike in many ways um the
modern manifestations of sexism do
mirror the modern manifestations of
racism where we have inherited an
historical set of of policies uh most of
which don't exist now but they're but
their
ghosts do right the manifestations
downstream still do well
[Music]
i believe what you've just said is
accurate but i want to add another
category here so there is some sort of
structural inherited bias against
work that has traditionally been female
but there's also an economic reason that
that would exist that has nothing to do
with any kind of bigotry right that
because women are
saddled with or privileged with
whichever way you want to see it the
actual production of babies and their
nursing
the economic model
would predict that that would be
budgeted in right and so that
well i mean i think
i know i interrupted you but you know as
we move to agriculture 10-ish 10 to
12-ish thousand years ago
most of us
um have ancestors that became
agriculturalists 10 to 12 000 years ago
as that as that began to happen
you know
for a while
everyone was working to support their
own family and that might have been
extended family but um as
trade became more common the things that
men were doing were tradable and
therefore monetizable and the things
that women were doing were less tradable
and monetizable until very very recently
and there are a lot of us who think that
that monetize monetizing of things like
you know of reproduction and sex
obviously sex has been monetized forever
but um you know things like surrogacy
um is a brand new phenomenon but for the
most part the things that are mandated
by anatomy and physiology that women do
was not brought into the market
except for you know actually having sex
you know prostitution is super old as we
all know
um and so the the work that men were
doing you know being able to sell the
grain to allow for um to purchase things
that you couldn't make at home
was was something that tracked men's
work and not women's work and you know
we can we could think of you know
putting up the food you know preserving
the food that was for a while anyway
more women's work but it also didn't
generate nearly as much of the potential
revenue and so you have this sort of you
know initial
um inherent inequality
not based inherently on any bigotry
right not based in in any bigotry now it
doesn't mean it's not structural it is
and it doesn't mean it can't be
structurally corrected it can um but the
point is let's you know it's tempting to
just simply
demonize a system that has biases in it
and
then those jump to bigotry is the only
possibility bigotry is the explanation
um and then as long as you're doing that
the other temptation is to do it
unevenly so all the crappy stuff that uh
men end up doing you know nobody's all
that eager to democratize that right the
the dying
as you're fending off tyranny the you
know descending into the sewers to break
up giant globs of fat right i mean right
like
these are not things that women are in
general
trying to break into so anyway there is
something to be done there's always
questions of fairness with respect to
access
but
come on these things just aren't simple
right no they're they're
really very much not and i like
i love that work that um that i was
reading about with the 185 uh
pre-agriculturalist societies or yeah
pre-industrial societies and i have but
you know i used to teach with us a lot i
used to use use that work to teach
descriptive statistics among other
things but i think it you know
everything in this book got so shortened
because it has such breadth um but the
point there about division of labor
persisting in across cultures across for
many activities
but which sex does it varies is
extraordinary i love this the fact that
in some cultures weaving is very much a
man's job and women shall not touch it
because it would you know sully the the
weaving or the men or something and in
other cultures it's exactly the opposite
story and of course the languaging
around it will come will be different
both because it's different cultures and
because um the reasons that we say that
women shouldn't touch things and men
shouldn't touch things tend to be
different as well
but you know
weaving well that's man's work weaving
that's women's work okay both things are
argued in different cultures at the same
time on the planet and that tells us
there's value and division of labor
without those divisions of labor
inherently having anything to do with
underlying differences in ability or
interest and the fact that that one goes
in both directions tells us that both
men and women weave well enough alone
okay that one will accept you'll accept
yes
[Music]
you